es ist paradox dass wenn noch immer
keine spuren von außerirdischen gefunden
haben und es gibt sogar einen namen für
dieses paradoxon dass fermi paradoxon
es beschreibt die eigentlich wirklich
sehr seltsame situation alien sollten
doch schon seit sehr langer zeit
existieren und zeit gehabt haben das
weltall zu erobern
doch nirgendwo findet sich eine spur der
beweis dafür dass es gar keine
außerirdischen gibt also gibt es nun
welche oder keine das klären wir jetzt
bei pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen und am ende des videos habe
ich noch ein kleines goodie für euch
so also ich gebe mich geschlagen ihr
habt das thema jetzt hunderte male
vorgeschlagen also hier ist es wenn es
denn außerirdisches leben geben sollte
und ihr wisst die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so klein
sollten wir es dann nicht überall um uns
herum haben denn schließlich müssen
intelligente außerirdische doch in der
lage sein die gesamte galaxie zu
kolonisieren und dann müssten wir doch
über hinweise zu ihnen nur so stolpern
dem ist aber nicht so toll da raus also
die schlussfolgerung dass es keine
intelligenten außerirdischen gibt dass
unsere ganze suche nach ihnen von
vornherein erfolglos ist und war genau
dieses gedankenexperiment soll der
physiker enrico fermi im jahr 1950
aufgestellt haben und zwar auf einem weg
zum mittagessen als er im gespräch mit
einigen seiner kollegen über
ufo-sichtungen und die existenz von
außerirdischen überhaupt war am ende so
heißt es soll er dann gesagt haben wer
is everybody dass wir trotz intensiver
suche keinerlei spuren von
außerirdischen leben finden sei einfach
nur paradox und so sei es höchste zeit
unsere annahmen dazu oder aber unsere
beobachtungen in diesem zusammenhang zu
hinterfragen doch das fermi paradoxon
sorgt bis heute zu hitzigen diskussionen
diskutiert wird sogar ob enrico fermi
diese behauptung überhaupt jemals
aufgestellt hat der amerikanische autor
robert brain beispielsweise der selbst
nach signalen von außerirdischen gesucht
hat bezweifle das sehr stark er ist
nicht der ansicht dass wir jemals ein
wort über außerirdische verloren habe
gray ist dagegen der festen überzeugung
dass das ganze auf einem missverständnis
basiert denn schließlich habe man nur
die erinnerung vom vermisst kollegen der
satz wer is everybody aus vermissen und
sei völlig anders zu interpretieren als
es das fermi paradoxon verbreite ein
kollege erinnerte sich demnach noch sehr
gut daran dass fermi selbst mit
spekulierte warum es bisher an
außerirdischen hinweisen fehlt der
physiker selbst habe überlegt das
interstellare reisen gegebenenfalls
einfach noch nicht möglich sein oder das
den außerirdischen der ganze aufwand
einfach nicht wert sein
so ging es bei seiner frage also eher
darum warum eine reise von stern so
stern nicht möglich ist das wundert
jedenfalls nicht denn zu diesem
zeitpunkt also 1950 hatte noch keine
rakete die erdumlaufbahn oder aber einen
anderen himmelskörper erreicht sputnik
war noch nicht im erdorbit angelangt
fermi soll demnach aber keineswegs
grundsätzlich an der existenz von
außerirdischen leben gezweifelt haben
doch das hat sich wohl so verfestigt mit
fatalen folgen 1981 beschloss der
amerikanische politiker william trox
meyer
das nasa programm namens seti finanziell
nicht weiter zu fördern
sie steht für search for
extraterrestrial intelligence und die
begründung für die beendigung des
programms musste damals und so für die
begründung
tatsächlich das fermi paradoxon er halt
975 jedenfalls dachte der astronom
michael hart weiter auf dem sogenannten
fermi paradoxon herum er argumentierte
tatsächlich dass die menschen die
einzigen intelligenten lebewesen in der
galaxis sein denn ansonsten hätte das
außerirdische leben dort bereits die
gesamte milchstraße erobert doch auch
hier gibt es wiederum viele die vehement
dagegen halten wer sagt denn dass sie
unbedingt neue galaxien kolonisieren
wollen oder unsere galaxie vielleicht
waren sie aber auch schon längst bei uns
und die beweise dafür sind zusammen mit
den dinosauriern von der erde
verschwunden und woher sollten die
außerirdischen überhaupt die ressourcen
haben um unzählige andere sterne zu
bereisen jedenfalls ist die bezeichnung
paradoxon irreführend denn wo ist der
widerspruch zwischen den beiden thesen
wir finden hier keine außerirdischen bei
uns und irgendwo wird es außerirdische
geben schließlich weiß niemand ob reisen
zwischen den sternen überhaupt möglich
sind fahrlässig ist es jedenfalls die
suche nach außerirdischen im kosmos
deswegen zu unterlassen weil wir bei uns
bisher keine hinweise darauf gefunden
haben schließlich haben wir bisher nicht
einmal einen bruchteil des kosmos unter
die lupe genommen und wir berichten hier
bei klicks und science fiction ja immer
wieder mal darüber dass wir selbst hier
auf der erde krasse erkenntnisse in
diesem zusammenhang machen
beispielsweise dass mikroben auch bei
extremen temperaturen überleben können
also eigentlich sprechen alle indizien
für die existenz von außerirdischen wer
weiß was die nächsten jahre bringen die
chancen für unsere suche steigen
jedenfalls wenn beispielsweise das
nasa-weltraumteleskop james webb
planeten auf die chemische
zusammensetzung ihrer atmosphäre
untersuchen wird ja und jetzt gibt es
zehn euro für jeden ungelogen meine web
community hat mich gebeten einen special
deal auszuhandeln
und ich habe ihn
bei dem von stiftung warentest am besten
getesteten cashback portal gibt es zehn
euro plus noch sondern schmeckt das
ganze bekommt die am morgigen sonntag
wenn ihr euch hier bei whatsapp anmeldet
einfach draufklicken whatsapp erfahrt
ihr auch von mir vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video täglich und garantiert
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken dem neuesten zu
indizien und spuren von leben auf dem
mars also da gibt es ja auch schon
weiter also bis dann lauter